it is really a pleasure to welcome today
to the program
tm garrett who's a former white
supremacist
turned human rights activist uh tm such
a pleasure to have you on i appreciate
your time
now thank you for having me so i mean
let's go to the beginning you started
sort of getting pulled into
um extremist and nationalist groups
when you were quite young i think it was
when you were 13.
um what what was initially appealing
about those groups
it wasn't actually the groups first um i
grew up in
a troubled family dysfunctional and i
was a bullied kid
um that was a lot of things that i
didn't understand why other kids
wouldn't play with me
and i was craving for a lot of attention
and i didn't get that attention i always
felt like
my wishes and my talents that were they
were overlooked my mom tried hard
she had a drinking problem but um she
hid it very well
she i never starved i always had good
school supplies and was always so
important to her that i have good grades
in school
so what i really wanted was overlooked
and since i didn't get the attention
that i wanted one time i found the one
thing that would give me the attention
it started with racist jokes at a
schoolyard when i was about 13
14 13 high school age
and you know a lot of kids did that but
the other kids went back to normal
the big problem was my normal would have
been the bullied kid that you can push
around
and for nothing in the world i would
have exchanged it again
so i ran longer with those jokes those
racist anti-semite jokes anti-semitic
jokes and everything
then the other kids because
i i didn't i didn't have anything um and
i was labeled as
a nazi kid at school and i didn't like
that first
but it had a side effect i wasn't
bullied anymore
and that was the point that why i ran
with it
and then it started with hate music it
was the late 80s
89 and a kid handed me the tape
and first it was not the real hardcore
stuff it was
it was skinhead music patriotic and they
were singing about how misunderstood
they were and people would call them
nazis but they were not
and they were afraid of immigration and
i grew up in that little town 500
citizens
there were no immigrants there were
nothing it was just
um 500 conservative people living there
and and that's all i knew and
for the first time when i heard that
music i thought somebody is listening to
me somebody
knows me without knowing me and that was
just amazing to me
at that point and with every cassette
tape i got the music got more radical
and that radicalized me too until to a
point when i
went and looked actively looked for for
skinhead
groups and i found one and joined that
group
and went from there and when you join
the group
how old are you first of all that was
about
the age of 15. okay and when you go to
that group
are most of the people in the group 15
or are they
older or significantly older than you
were at
i was pretty much the youngest they were
all about 17
18 19 the oldest was about 20. and
pretty much
all of them at that time it was a lot
more about subculture
at that time um went back to normal
it to their normal when they were like
21 22
23 um it was like the punks
they would get back to normal too but in
that case there was often that
extremist right-wing ideology in the
background too
so when they went back to their normal
in their minds they were still
extremists which i didn't understand
back then too
um but it was it was not a gang like you
would imagine here in the u.s
it was overseas in germany and all of
them either went to school or had jobs
um and there was no drug selling or
anything
and but it was still the music and there
was fights and we got drunk and
everything that was appealing to me
and then the music and it got more
radical and first it was just
about being proud to be a german and at
some point it was about
foreigners out and seek hell and that
radicalized me over the years
and when it comes to the rhetoric
becoming
real world action i mean how much were
the people you were around
going beyond just the rhetoric and the
music and doing
things to other people or like in the
real world as we might say
well it started actually when i joined
that first group because the music
promoted that violence
against anybody we got drunk hammered
and were actively looking for fights
and i was at that time i was 15. i was
more shy kid
so i didn't get very much along with
that um
i liked the music but i didn't like to
transfer that in the real world and
every time we got in fights i tried to
be in the background
which didn't earn me the best reputation
at the time but i remember the leader of
that skinhead crew
i remember one time one guy was saying
well your skinhead career will either
end in prison or in a wheelchair
and that that was very describing i
remember that very well because
if we didn't find any other gang that we
could fight
or if we didn't find one of our enemies
we could fight
well you would just pick somebody
amongst your own people
just to fight and that that was in the
days when i was a skinhead and at the
age of 17 i joined a far-right party in
germany
and that's when the nationalist thought
came more
into the game can you talk a little bit
about how
sincere you and the other people in the
groups were
about the beliefs and i'll give you a
little more context so that i'm clear
about the question
when i've spoken to other former kkk
people
former white nationalists here in the
united states
they would very often say that they were
sort of going along for the ride with
the beliefs like they didn't
really literally believe the
anti-semitic stuff
that was circulating they sort of
believed it it wasn't the most important
thing but the community was the most
important thing and they often talk
about sort of this neglected childhood
that you also talk about in your case
how sincere were your extremist beliefs
and do you think the others in the group
shared those
well it started with that craving for a
belonging
for a family for a purpose that is why i
joined the first skinhead group
yeah um and i looked for an identity
because i didn't have one like other
kids they had an identity as a boy scout
they had an identity
i don't know fans of a certain sports
team or whatever the dads would take
them
to the games or watch the games on tv i
didn't have a dad he died
when i was young my mother never
remarried so that was missing so i
looked for that family of course
and when i radicalized and i joined the
far-right party
and later um i got more in touch with
white supremacists worldwide through the
internet that it was uh
in the year 1998 roundabout
and i radicalized more and more and i
was
i was hardcore as it can get i believed
that
i believed that the jews were taking
over the world i was
i really believed that the race war
would start anytime soon
uh we were waking up already had
nightmares that the police would come
kick in our doors with the search
warrant and stuff like that and
the others in the group believe that two
of course there were a couple
there were more along for the ride but i
i became one of the
leaders and influencers and i lived that
i was breathing it i was waking up with
it i was going to bed with it
and it was exhausting can you talk about
what you imagined you would eventually
accomplish
by your membership in these groups and
to this ideology in other words
the ideology was the basis
but what did you see as the end goal was
it the extermination of certain peoples
was it i mean what did what did you
think you would be able to do
well that that depended
on which group i belong to when i
started being in those skinhead groups
uh the skinheads always
looked at themselves as the
stormtroopers like in the third reich
you had the ss and the the party
and the leadership and you had the
fighting troops and
that's how we saw ourselves so we're
trying to
achieve that um and we're hoping
that there would be another a fourth
reich
without foreigners without jews hanging
the
traitors that's kind of what we believed
in and
that got radicalized a little bit more
like the methods how we want to reach it
first it was
that stormtrooper type thing then it was
in that far-right party okay we can
reach it through elections
like actually what hitler did he got
elected and took over power and change
changed the laws he thought we can do
that
and then with the opening of the
internet in 1998
and i became more concerned about the
white race
than just the nation i lived in um
i thought we just have to unite it as
white people
and especially in europe
and i don't know how i
tried to achieve that at that point it
was a period of two years i
i really wasn't sure and then i joined
the kkk
and that was a weird thing because in
germany um
the extremist far right is not based on
a christian
belief system like it is here in the u.s
or often
not always it's more based on the
germanic
nordic pagan belief system they have and
then you have the clan praying to
jesus who was a jew and you can turn and
twist it whatever
he was a jew yeah and i could wrap my
head around that
so i started studying scriptures trying
to find those
famous translation errors and everything
and then looking back
we had that idea of the
influential kkk that has governors that
has
judges that has police officers
secret knowledge maybe it's the elite
i didn't think of any trailer park trash
or anything at the time i just looked
what did you read in books maybe or old
movies
and i thought this is how we could do it
we could
infiltrate society
and reach our goals that way can you
talk
a little bit about what started your
i guess we would call it like
de-radicalization
process was it some of these
contradictions that you started to
identify or what triggered you starting
to question what you were doing
well it happened on my journey through
all those groups
i always had questions and i think every
person that is in any kind of extremist
group that doesn't even have to be a
white white supremacist hate group it
can be any kind of extremist group
has the same questions and the same
doubts
you know if you have doubts you live in
a bubble you don't talk to anybody
outside of that bubble you take your
dots put it on a stack
on that stack gets bigger bigger bigger
until it's a mountain
and you know the people in the bible
they don't want you to leave they
reassure you everything is all right
they
will tell you everything is fine
okay we seem to have lost our connection
to tm garrett a
former white supremacist turned human
rights activist
fascinating conversation for as long as
it lasted i i don't know
what happened uh in terms of his
connection but we will
i would like to continue talking with
him maybe we will have him back on
uh i guess we will go to a break and
then continue with more of the program
uh coming up after this tm garrett
former white supremacist
now a human rights activist and maybe
next time we can learn more about the
human rights
activist work